let's let's talk about uh other signs of
the apocalypse instead of just
defamation we had the story from fox
business biden considers tapping
emergency diesel reserve with prices
near record high
yes you may have seen the story that
there's going to be a diesel shortage
that diesel is at what six dollars a
gallon people uh who drive trucks are
saying it's costing them a thousand
bucks to fill up so they don't even know
if they want to do the job anymore and
uh then you have
over and over again these memes
particularly from people on the left
saying it's not biden's fault biden
can't do anything about gas prices it's
the greedy corporations i give you this
from uh this is from may 19th only a few
days ago but you absolutely gotta listen
to it this is uh josh hawley was our
audio right
as uh oh yeah it never is is it
i always gotta listen to music before
the show that's right secretary grantham
today in the state of missouri the
average price of gasoline today as of
this morning is four dollars and ten
cents
average price of diesel is five dollars
and 18 cents
and i'm sure you've seen the reporting
this morning that now aaa is projecting
that gas prices will hit a national
average average of six dollars a gallon
by the month of august
is this acceptable to you no it is not
and you can thank the activity of
vladimir putin for invading ukraine and
pulling us
with all due respect madam secretary
that's utter nonsense in january of 2021
the average gas price of my state was
two dollars and seven cents eight months
later
eight months later long before vladimir
putin invaded ukraine that price was up
over 30 percent and it has been going up
consistently since
what are you doing to reverse this
administration's policies that are
drawing down our own supply of energy in
this country that are throttling oil and
gas production in the united states of
america what are you doing about it
respect sir it is not administration
policies that have affected supply and
demand how can you say that when the
price of gas was up over 30 percent from
january to you answer my questions and
it's my time madam secretary so why
don't you answer my question from
january to august the price of gasoline
was up over 30 percent in my state alone
it has been a continuous a continuous
upward tick since then
and here's what your president did when
he first came to office he immediately
re-entered the paris climate accord he
canceled the keystone pipeline he halted
leasing programs in anwar he issued a
60-day halt
on all new oil and gas leases and
drilling permits on federal lands and
waters that's nationwide that accounts
by the way for 25 percent of u.s oil
production he directed federal agencies
to eliminate all supports for fossil
fuels he imposed new regulations on oil
and gas and methane emissions those were
all just in the first few days are you
telling me that's had no effect on our
energy
so uh yeah i think it's fair to say that
he he very much listed the policy
changes that have impacted the price of
gas and can i just point out something i
think common sense
when you have a political party that has
been screaming climate change and carbon
emissions
do you think they're the party that's
going to get you cheap gas
i mean no
if you are someone who is also worried
about climate change you're probably
happy that joe biden did those things
the repercussions are regular
working-class people aren't going to be
afford to drive food prices are going to
skyrocket there's going to be shortages
of diesel
and if we if we have to tap into the
strategic reserves i wonder considering
the fertilizer shortage already what's
food going to look like this fall when
the harvest comes and ain't nothing
coming through winter is coming my
friends and
when they try and claim it's vladimir
putin who did this
here's what i hear i hear them saying
we did this
and we're glad we did this but we don't
want you yelling at us because we're
gonna do it more so we need a
scapegoat so yeah get ready for it's
gonna get worse yeah the the fertilizer
situation is really critical uh already
you see you know obviously what's
happening in the ukraine has really just
shut off all of that grain
and then india of course has they've cut
off their exports and you really have to
wonder in in the long run and when i say
the long run i mean in the next year or
two
where we're going to be because if you
don't have the fertilizer and if you
have an industrial farming system right
the fertilizer the the petroleum-based
fertilizers are essential to the food
supply
but you don't have food the only thing
you then have are stores now i think
america will be okay i think you know
most of europe will be okay they'll hurt
but in the third world it will be
crushing it already is i mean
you got sri lanka yeah and there's
there's politics involved in that right
some of their policies and stuff but it
is already affecting many other places
as well um i think the us will be
okay
but you ain't going to be happy no and
when you have unhappy people and you
have a whole lot of guns and you have a
whole lot of anger
things happen look at look at the baby
formula situation
now that now we're importing and it's
just it's so laughable how people defend
joe biden like look he's solving the
problem it's like bro you don't get
credit for solving the problem you made
you know it's it's
if you if you spill milk on my floor i'm
not gonna congratulate you when you mop
it up i'm gonna be i'm gonna be like
please don't do that again
mopping it up was the least you can do
this is what we're dealing with now with
the
you're gonna get angry people
you know
babies is bad enough but i think we're
gonna see uh a lot of shortages yeah i
saw an article that said that uh you can
take uh methane and break it into
hydrogen and graphene so there are ways
out of this but i people are so hooked
on the short-term oil
for whatever reason we have been for the
last 40 years of my life 43 years i
don't know i don't know it's always like
it's just two years away just five years
away just like what are we waiting for
it's real simple we built a world on oil
we are now standing on the pillars of
fossil fuels
that's why we need them you can't just
take that away because then
your tower will fall and that fall is
going to kill a lot of people so what
can we do i mean
slow changes
build new infrastructure to hold up our
civilization with alternate energies
nuclear power sounds like a great idea
i'm a big fan of renewables tidal energy
geothermal all really great
instead it just seems like
the people who are deeply concerned
about climate change and and there are a
lot i think climate change is is is an
issue i think pollution's an issue i
think dead zones are an issue but
it's it's i think the real argument here
is human experience versus
non-human experience that is to say
if you were to just shut off the oil
right now like greta tunberg wants and
just kill 60 some odd million people
because all of a sudden i mean as i have
to mention diabetics are the first to go
when the power goes out then it's you
know no food no transport nor no heating
so you really are just the the people
who are vulnerable just 60 million i
think is the estimate you can do that
but the human experience is why we're
here so you have these two trains of
thought one that it doesn't matter what
humans perceive think want it human
perception is irrelevant therefore
let's just stabilize the ecosystem and
you know that results in how many people
dead then you have people who are like
okay look you know we can we can be
better stewards of this planet while
recognizing that we are humans we
perceive things in human way and we want
to protect
human life and what what cause brings us
joy in which case yeah just this
utilitarian kill as many people as
possible for the sake of reducing carbon
doesn't work
well you know i i differ with many of
those on the right on this topic uh i i
do think that obviously our job as
humans is to survive right that's the
the core
other than salvation let's say the
essential task of the human being is to
survive but in the last 150 200 years
the absolute destruction on the
environment that has been wrought
primarily through technology can't be
ignored and well i think climate change
is somewhat of a red herring uh it's
it's dubious as to whether or not the
evidence backs up the theory and
ultimately it's a kind of slow-moving
thing what we do have in our faces right
now as you say pollution the dead zones
but really habitat loss particularly
like in the amazon or in africa which is
driven primarily by china at this point
but also the species loss i mean once
they're gone they're gone and i think
that that
the reason that
radical environmentalists are so
passionate about this and i feel very
much in the same way is that we are at a
critical point that you're just because
there's trees everywhere doesn't mean
you have an old ecosystem right you go
to the apple
you look at the appalachian mountain
range all of that's new growth all of it
it was cut down sometimes twice 150 200
years ago 250 years ago so what you have
now all over the earth what is still
green is in the southern hemisphere and
that's being rapidly eroded again
primarily by china and i i don't know
what the way around it is but i do think
that the urgency that's one reason i'm
so frustrated by people like greta
tinberg right she's a joke it's
hilarious to watch her she makes funny
memes that that swedish death metal meme
hilarious but it completely covers up
the real critical issue
that
we are still to this day as we have for
two centuries destroying the natural
environment and it's never coming back
so we have to find some someplace in
between
but you know as it's been pointed out by
many on the right in america for
instance uh you know many of those in
the sierra club who founded these the
sierra club
you could say at least by today's
standards are very right-wing especially
on issues of immigration but if you
don't have a country right if it's not
if it's no longer your country and you
don't have harmony you don't have
cohesion you don't have any way of
exerting your will anymore well then
you're not going to save the environment
and you're not going to save yourself so
i do think that again starting local i
think the equation is actually fairly
simple
people scream climate change
the world economic forum says you will
own nothing you will be happy
the people who are claiming that the
earth is being destroyed are not the
ones who are going to give you a good
economy absolutely
donald trump
gives us this roaring economy and growth
that you know obama said wasn't possible
yeah well growth means more kids more
kids means exponential growth so
certainly the people who are like
climate changes destroying the planet
are not going to be happy that donald
trump was doing that right no so then
when joe biden the democrats the party
of climate change gets into power what
are they going to do
they're probably going to enact policies
to reverse what trump did
hurting people
but
benefiting their ideology
that is not a moral statement on climate
change what we should or shouldn't do on
the environment it is a fact statement
joe biden helping people
giving them a better economy giving them
cheap fuel meant they were going to eat
it meant they were going to have
children it meant these values are going
to create more people if you are bill
gates and you're like we need less
people you're not going to be happy with
donald trump now are you you're going to
want the opposite unfortunately the
opposite means that for you at home your
milk costs 10 bucks your your gas is
going to cost 10 bucks and you're going
to own nothing
and you're going to have to live with it
you're not going to be happy but that's
what they want for you yeah so you made
a point earlier about how people
especially people in developing
countries are really going to suffer
from this and i remember when the
lockdowns were first beginning it was
estimated i believe by the imf or the
world bank that about 120 million people
were going to be added to the category
of being in extreme poverty as a result
of covet 19 though of course what
they're referring to specifically were
the lockdowns and we'll get into that
euphemism in a moment but
we we see this i've seen some sources
that say after 2021 they updated that
number to 100 million after they saw the
effects it actually had and it's really
sad because that group of people has
been totally forgotten and they use this
euphemism as i mentioned where they say
you know a hundred million people have
been
added or found themselves in extreme
poverty because of covet 19. well no
it's because of the lockdowns and the
breakdown of the supply chain we know
this just look at the states in america
which locked up and which didn't lock up
we know you're going to have far more
disastrous consequences for your economy
if you do shut down over something like
this and so the left for years was
claiming if you cut even a penny of what
we intend to allocate towards welfare
spend spending hundreds and hundreds of
people are going to die but then when it
comes down to shutting down the global
supply chain
or at least the part that every
developed country in the world plays in
the global supply chain well that's
that's a risk we're willing to take and
you know if it just saves one life let's
ignore the fact that many many many
people will die thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there